-Our first guest is an Emmy-
and Tony-nominated actor
you know from his work
as Chief of Police Jim Hoppe
in the award-winning serie
"Stranger Things."
Next month, he stars
in Marvel's highly anticipated
"Black Widow,"
as well as "No Sudden Move,"
which begins streaming
on HBO Max on July 1st.
Let's take a look.
-I was going to tell her.
I was going to tell her.
And then, Peggy had a bird
feeder thing, and I'm --
I -- It doesn't matter.
And now, there's another thing
And I just --
-I told Phil,
as per our promise.
-I need to get into
the green safe right now.
-Why?
He cried, Matt.
Phil, he cried.
-I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
The combination
of the green safe is what?
-I came to work from
the Humpty Dumpty Motel.
-I'm sorry.
I need the combination
to the green safe.
-Please welcome back to th
show David Harbour, everybody!
♪♪♪♪
Hi, buddy. How are you?
Welcome back.
So nice to see you.
-Thanks for having me.
♪♪♪♪
-I really like --
There is a real nice shape
to your beard right now.
I feel like we've seen it
in a lot of different
ways over the years.
-Thank you, man.
I just cut it with some scissors
over the sink right
before I got here.
For real,
like, very pandemic style.
-Yeah, I would have assumed --
I guess that was a skill
you must have learned
in the pandemic.
-I mean, yeah.
I guess so, yeah.
You know -- you pick --
I've had the beard a lot.
So you pick things
like that up, yeah.
-Yeah, alright.
Well, I'm glad to hear it.
The last time --
I think it's safe to say
the last time
you were in this building
was when you hosted "SNL."
It's been a year and a half.
You did a great job.
-Thanks man, thanks.
It was amazing.
That's like a real dream
come true.
-Yeah, I mean, I'm assumin
you had some nerves about it
-Yeah, it's terrifying.
I mean, I --
I mean, Lorne even said it's
like being shot out of a cannon.
You show up and there
is nothing written.
You're going to have to do
an hour and a half show
five days from then.
And then, basically,
you don't get any material
until Wednesday, right?
-Yeah.
-And then on Saturday, you'r
doing a show. It's terrifying.
-And how is it compared to being
here, which is not live?
It's live to tape
in front of nobody.
Do you feel the same nerves?
[ Laughter ]
-It's a little less.
-Yeah, a little less? Okay
well, thanks for your honesty.
How about being back
in the world?
Have you been out?
I know that's a thing not just
actors but all human being
are a little worried about
interacting with humans again.
-No, I mean, it's great.
I've been really excited to,
you know, open up.
I've just been harassing
celebrities
and things like that.
-Oh, so celebrities
are just like us
in that they get harassed
by other celebrities.
-Harassed by me, yeah.
We harass other celebrities.
-Who did you harass?
-So, it was like
one of the first days
out of the pandemic,
and I was in London.
I was in Notting Hill,
and things started to open up,
coffee shops and stuff
like that.
And I went out with my mask.
I was kind of walking around
I was so excited because I saw
Chris Pine
like way across the street
on the corner.
And I was --I had my mask
on and everything.
But I was like,
"Yo, Chris Pine."
Actor, you know,
I was like, "Hey, hey."
And he looked back at me
and he was like...
And I was like,
"No, no, no, no, no, man."
I took off my mask.
I went, "Hey."
And he went...
[ Laughter ]
And I walked up.
He's just going like --
[Bleep] [Bleep]
[ Laughter ]
Just like --
-Don't feel like
you've nailed that one.
-Awful. Awful.
-Yeah.
Have you ever met him
or was it --
-No.
-Okay, gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
-That's not true.
I met him once I think
at a party.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Yeah.
-But it wasn't like --
-But also, I gotta say.
Like, something about
that story was like,
it's not like it was Al Pacino
Like, God, you know what I mean?
-Yeah.
-It's like Chris Pine.
Like, good, you know,
but I really, like,
fanboyed out too hard
and it was very embarrassing
-See, I feel like Pacino
would have come right over
[ Laughter ]
I feel like
you wave to Al Pacino.
[ as Pacino ]
Hey, "Stranger Things."
Hey, you alive
in "Stranger Things?"
[ Laughter ]
Tell me the truth!
-It is an excellent
impersonation.
-[ Normal voice ] Thank you.
It's kind of gone away.
-Anybody who tells
you different is just jealous.
-Yeah, I think so.
It is jealousy, right?
It's abject jealousy.
-Yeah.
-Hey, congratulations.
You got married.
And part of the bargain,
a really good part of bargain,
you have two stepdaughters
I've got a couple boys.
-How old are yours?
-Mine are five and three.
-Five and three. Yeah. Okay.
Yeah, I have two stepdaughters
They're eight and nine.
-How is that?
-Very close in age.
I mean, it's amazing and also,
it's horrible.
I have to say, you know,
I wanted to say --
tell a little story about them
But I have to say,
you know, to them,
because they sometimes
watch this on YouTube.
-Sure.
-I just want to say
you both are very special girls.
I love you very much, okay
-That's good.
They'll remember that part
-Okay, good.
The other day, we were --
you know, Marnie,
who's the young one,
she just hit her sister.
And I, you know, I was like,
"Marnie!"
I took her up to her room.
I'm like,
"You can't hit your sister."
And she said,
"Look, she hit me first."
And I said, "Well,
I didn't see that.
All I saw was you hit her.
And it doesn't matter
if she hit you.
You can't hit your sister.
You just can't.
Even if she hits you."
And she said, "Well what do yo
do if somebody hits you?
You have to hit them back.
And I was like,
"That is a real conundrum.
Like, I don't really have
an answer for that.
Because you're kind of right."
-Yeah.
Like, you can't be a door step
But I said, "We have to figure
this out
because I just can't have yo
hitting your sister."
And she -- I said,
"Let's think."
I was like, "Maybe you can com
tell us if she hits you."
And her face got really dark
And she looked away,
and she went,
"That's not gonna work."
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "Alright, well
we'll think about it.
We'll just think
about a way to do this."
-You're like,
"You think about it.
I'm going to lock the door
So you're in here."
-So, I walk out.
I walk out of the door
and there's Ethel, her sister,
like, right outside the door
like, going, "Hi, David."
And I was like, "Hey!
How's it going?"
She's like, "Oh, it's good
How are you? How's Marnie?
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "She's good.
She's like,
"What did you guys talk about?
And I was like,
"You little -- like -- you -
She's not a snitch!"
I felt like Eliot Ness
or something.
I was like, "It's okay."
-Yeah.
-"Your secret is safe." Yeah
-Oh, fantastic.
-Yeah, it was great.
It was really great.
-This movie
is a Soderbergh movie.
It's the first time
you worked with Soderbergh
-Yeah.
-And this is really just a top
to bottom incredible cast.
-Yeah.
-A lot of people worked
with him before,
but this was your first time
-Yeah, I mean, I was terrified
That guy's a real genius.
-Yeah.
-And he does it all.
He writes, he directs,
the whole thing.
But I was very intimidated
But I'm not alone
in being intimidated by him.
He -- I was in the gym
at the hotel.
We're all like cordoned off.
You know, I'm in the gym in th
hotel and I bump into Benicio.
And, like, Benicio del Toro,
one of the great actors
of our time
and just such a presence.
And I was like, "Hey, man.
He's like, "Hey."
And immediately got to work.
He was like, "Hey, man,
don't you think this thing
in the script is like this
It could be like a little better
if it was like this."
And I was like, "Yeah.
That's a great idea, man.
You should tell Steven.
Like, just that little tweet
would be great."
And he goes, "Ma-- Maybe
you could tell him."
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "What are you
talking about, man?
He said, "No, just maybe it come
better from you, man."
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "What? No, man
You won an Oscar in 'Traffic
that he directed."
"I just think maybe
you could tell him."
[ Laughter ]
We're all terrified of him
-That's so funny.
-We were all terrified.
-Because he comes off
as very unassuming.
-I mean, he's super nice.
He's just hard to read.
It's hard to know
if he likes you.
And he's just so focused
on doing his thing.
And he's such a genius
that yeah,
none of us were comfortabl
approaching him.
-One thing I'm very happy abou
and I don't think I'm alone.
Last time you were here,
nobody really knew if you were
going to be in season four o
"Stranger Things."
Now we have confirmation.
-Yeah.
-And has that been nice no
to finally be able
to tell people again?
-Yeah, it's really great.
I mean, I'm really happy
we did it before the pandemic.
We had that trailer come out
-Yeah.
-And thank God that people
you know, know about it.
Because I don't know
how I would have kept this
secret for much longer.
-Yeah.
Well, that's nice
that that's back.
And it is really exciting.
"Black Widow" as well.
So there's a lot coming.
-Yeah.
Yeah, it's a big month if yo
like David Harbour movies.
[ Laughter ]
This is your month!
-[ as Pacino ]
Oh, it's my month, baby?
-[ as Pacino ] Hoo-ah!
-David Harbour back-to-back!
[ Laughter ]
-Yours is better.
Yours is better.
-[ Normal voice ] No, no,
please. You're just jealous.
"No Sudden Move"
begins streaming on HBO Ma
on July 1st and "Black Widow
will be in theaters on July 9th.